BEN TREYNOR SLOSS: Hi,
I'm Ben Treynor Sloss.
I'm the Vice President
of 24/7 here at Google.
And I'm here today
to talk to you
about reliability in the cloud.
Leveraging cloud
allows customers
to achieve outcomes of scale,
reach, speed, and flexibility,
which would be difficult
or impossible to achieve
for many companies
and many services.
For this talk,
I'm going to focus
on reaching high
levels of reliability
for services running
in the cloud.
Here at Google,
we've been building
extremely reliable services in
the cloud for two decades now.
And along the way, we've learned
a lot about what works well,
and we've also found
some pitfalls that we're
going to help you avoid.
Cloud offers a lot of
power and a lot of options
for building reliable systems,
and that flexibility is great.
But it also means
that cloud offers
some new and interesting ways
to get reliability wrong.
And because public
clouds work differently
than many traditional on-premise
data center environments,
the reliability paradigm
that works well in cloud
is also somewhat different
from a traditional [INAUDIBLE],,
and we'll cover that.
So today, I'm going to give you
a framework for understanding
your reliability goals
and how to achieve
those goals in the cloud.
I'll cover three distinct
topics, defining requirements,
choosing an
architecture and design,
and implementation and
execution in deployment.
This talk is adapted from
Google's own internal best
practices for building
and maintaining
cloud-based systems.
And we use those same
practices to implement
both customer-facing
products, like Search, Gmail,
and YouTube, as well as our
own cloud infrastructure.
So first, you need to
define business requirements
for reliability.
And I want to emphasize
how important this step is.
This is the requirements
stage for reliability.
And we all know intellectually
that getting requirements
just so is critical
before you proceed
to design and implementation.
But we also know in
practice that sometimes we
don't spend enough
time on requirements,
and that can be especially
true for a requirement that
seems a little soft or
squishy like reliability.
So when we talk
about reliability,
often the temptation is to say,
our reliability requirement
is 100%, or it always works.
Or we assume that the
infrastructure provider
is going to be perfect.
And that turns out to be
close, but not actually
the correct reliability target.
So the outcome of
this exercise will
be reliability requirements
and targets for you to use,
along with a way
to measure them.
So this slide is critical.
It is the central idea behind
our approach to reliability,
and this comes from
our own experience.
What we find is that
there is a sweet spot
for setting a
reliability target, which
balances between the
two basic considerations
that we have in reliability.
The first is user expectations.
If your product is
insufficiently reliable--
you select too low a target
and you deliver that target--
users will not
like your product,
and they will eventually
leave you for a competitor.
And everyone pretty
much understands this.
A product that simply
doesn't work most of the time
is not going to be
a great product.
But what we don't
understand quite as often
is that if your
product was perfect,
if it delivered 100% uptime,
your users' experience will
still be far from
perfect, because there
are lots of sources
of unreliability
in the end-to-end chain
that your user experiences.
Their device may not work.
If you have a mobile
device and it malfunctioned
one time in 1,000 when you
were trying to reach some site,
you would say, that's a
very good, very reliable
mobile device.
Yet, that's only three nines.
And so if your users can't tell
the difference between three
nines of availability
and perfect availability,
then the user
benefit that you get
from making your applications
far more reliable
is de minimis.
But part two, the
cost of reliability
goes up exponentially as
you approach perfection.
And so you can see on this
chart, this basic idea.
As reliability
approaches perfect,
the user benefit
becomes nearly zero,
and the cost rises
exponentially.
And so the perfect
target for reliability,
which balances the cost in
terms of both direct dollars
and your development
philosophy of reliability
and the marginal benefit
of increased reliability,
turns out not to be 100%
for your application,
but rather a number
that's very close to 100%.
A very common number
is 99.95% availability,
up to 99.99%
availability, simply
because the other systems
that are in between you
and your user typically are
not more reliable than that
to begin with.
And picking this target, which
is just shy of perfection,
both keeps your costs way
down and also allows you
the ability to develop new
features and new functions
for users much more
quickly, because you're
spending less engineering
time on working on perfection.
And in practice, that ends
up being a good choice
for achieving user happiness.
So when we look at
reliability, in addition
to this idea of picking
a conscious choice that's
a bit short of perfection,
the other thing that we find
is that it's really important
to do the reliability exercise
in a coordinated way across
your different teams.
This allows you
to make decisions
about the reliability
of product components
that support the user
actions that they're
taking with your application.
And here, in turn, not
all user activities
have the same requirements
for reliability.
And for your business
or for their value,
different activities have
different expectations.
And that, again, is
an opportunity for you
to strike a more cost-efficient
and appropriate balance
on the whole for your users
and for your application
instead of holding every
part of your system
to the same high watermark
of the most critical user
activities.
This approach also helps you
avoid unexpected and unwanted,
uneven behavior of your
application where some parts
work very, very well-- maybe
more well than you need them--
and other parts
disappoint your user,
because they don't work
as well as it's required.
So let's talk about how
to define this process.
In Google terms,
we use something
called SLIs, or service
level indicators,
as a way of measuring the
end-to-end availability
of a particular user activity.
And we use SLOs, or
service level objectives,
as a term to describe
the expectation for how
those SLIs emerge in
practice for our users.
And so if you end up with
SLIs that accurately measure
your users' activities and SLOs
that numerically describe what
those SLIs should be in
a well-running system,
you have something
very useful, which
is a set of measurements
that are machine measurable.
So you can actually measure
them, constantly record them,
go back and look at them
later, alert on them
when they aren't working
the way you want.
And they also allow you to tie
the behavior of your system
to specific components and
specific development teams who
are working on the system.
And that, in turn, allows you
to manage your development
and deployment
process, and it allows
you to make decisions
about how you
run your service on a cloud.
So that's all a very
abstract concept.
Let's talk about
this in practice.
And I'll use, obviously,
a made up example here,
but one that we can
mostly relate to.
So suppose I'm doing an
assessment for a banking
application.
And as you can
see on this slide,
I've listed the business
goals in priority order.
We have several user
activities, and those activities
map to business goals.
For each of those goals, I have
mapped out the relevant user
activities in my application.
And I can see that,
really, my top goal
is to retain the
customers that I've got.
And I know that in
order to do that,
I need to be sure
that the users can
conduct their most common
and important activities--
logging in, checking
their account balance,
accessing their money--
very, very reliably.
So for each of these steps, I've
defined SLIs, and in this case,
have defined that the
user flow consists
of logging in,
accessing their balance,
accessing the application
to begin with.
And I can instrument this with
test devices and emulators,
and I can break apart the
front end and the back end
so that I get more
fine-grained SLIs.
But at the end of the day, the
crucial SLI that I'm measuring
is this user journey of
opening up the application,
logging in, and
performing the activity.
And so now I can look at
what the user experience is.
I can break it down into
the sub-pieces of the user
experience, so that
I can tune or debug.
And I can have an
overall measurement
that tells me whether the
application is working
the way I want it
to and, therefore,
the way that the users
will be happy with.
Now, there are some
other user activities
that are described
here, and we can see
that those are lower priority.
It doesn't mean that
they're not important.
Obviously, if we can't sell
our users new products,
that's very bad
for the business.
But the reliability requirements
for those activities
is actually somewhat different.
For example, if someone
applies to take out a loan
and there's a problem
with the system,
it's probably a
reasonable result to say,
application received and
we'll have an answer for you
within 30 minutes.
Even if you wanted
your ideal result
to be that the user gets
the answer that instant,
you'll have relatively low
attrition by the short delay.
But that covers for a
huge amount of downtime.
30 minutes a month is not even
four nines of availability.
So this idea of describing and
documenting your different user
journeys and assigning
them an appropriate SLO
allows you the freedom to either
allocate development resources
or allocate money in a
way that lets you build
a great product for your
user, rather than focusing
on making everything perfect.
So with this concept of
SLO and SLI I describe,
let's talk about
architecture and design
and how to achieve those
numeric goals for availability.
So the first step,
obviously, is you'll
have to choose a cloud
provider or cloud providers.
And you'll have to learn how
their infrastructure works well
enough to know how it
can support the SLOs
that you've chosen
for your own service.
So first thing to
realize is regardless
of which cloud
provider you choose,
they will also not be perfect.
That cloud provider
will consume part
of the unavailability budget
that is inherent in every SLO.
And this would be true whether
you were building something
on-premise or whether you were
building it with a public cloud
provider.
And each of them has different
services that they offer
and different SLOs
for that service.
And so this is where it's
very important for you
to look at the services
that are provided,
and the SLOs that are
given for the services,
and also the SLOs that
you could realistically
expect if you were to build
that same service yourself.
And questions to
ask at this stage,
knowing what SLO you're
aiming to achieve
with your own application,
are, does the provider offer
infrastructure
components that exceed
the measured and actual
uptime that you've experienced
with your on-prem environment?
Not your targets, but what
have you seen in practice?
Does the provider
offer tools that
make the whole
stack more reliable,
tools that allow you to
debug or quickly discover
where there are problems,
reducing the duration
of any down time you may have?
And does the
provider make it easy
for you to achieve your
desired outcomes with SLOs?
And this step really requires
some digging and some research.
But it pays off hugely,
because it affects
how you build your
application and how
you deploy your application,
and then, again, the end
result of how your users
experience your application.
So when deciding which
provider can best
support your reliability
SLOs, you also
want to look at
the infrastructure
that they offer, in terms
of zones and regions.
And this is a
concept that is now
common across all of the
public cloud providers.
But basically, zones are the
fundamental building block
of cloud infrastructure.
They're easy to reason
about, and they're
easy to program for.
The analogy is a
single data center.
And like a single data center,
they are both well understood
and there is limits to
how much reliability you
can expect from a single zone.
So if you need more reliability
than a single zone can offer,
then you're going to need
to run your application
in multiple zones
or multiple regions.
And if we go that route,
it's important to understand
what you get and
what you also don't
get from both running
in multiple zones
in the same region or
running in multiple zones
in multiple regions.
So let's talk about
infrastructure unavailability.
The easy outages and
the ones that we often
find we're talking
with customers about
are the ones on the left.
You picture a data center.
You picture a data
center on fire.
It just jumps to mind.
Well, it jumps to mind if
you've been doing reliability
for 20 years.
It jumps to my mind.
You picture floods.
You picture tornadoes.
You picture utility
power failures.
These are the big, very
dramatic, very easy
to empathize with outages.
But in practice, if you
look at the headlines
from the last five
years and say,
well, what have been the
causes of public cloud provider
infrastructure
downtime, it's actually
not any of those things.
All of the interesting
outages that we see--
almost all of the outages--
are really due to software
or external software
events and not
these dramatic, easy
to imagine hardware failures.
So you have network
control plane failures.
You have global denial
of service attacks.
You a BGP hijacks.
You have authentication
system failures.
You have configuration
changes that went awry.
None of these
things are actually
related to any of the hardware.
None of them would
cause the data center
to look like a tornado
had gone through it.
The data center
would look identical.
And yet, the impact
on your service
and the impact on that
particular zone region
is the same.
Everything stops working.
So while we're on this topic, we
can actually talk a little bit
about current events.
We can learn from what's
happened with the COVID-19
pandemic.
With COVID, we saw
another unexpected event
that really caused no damage
to the physical infrastructure,
but caused huge changes in
the usage pattern from users.
And for here at Google,
we saw, for example,
huge increases in
video conferencing
use with our Meet product.
And while we were able
to scale-up and meet
that demand through
moving resources around,
we also saw other
instances in industry
where demand clearly had
surged, and the providers
or the services struggled to
meet the increased demand.
And that was, if you will,
a failure of scalability
or a failure of flexibility,
still a logical failure rather
than a physical failure,
but one more example
of why the things that
you should worry about
are not the things that
look dramatic or appear
in your mind's eye, so much
as the logical problems that
actually are a bit
more mundane but really
dominate the downtime
that we measure
when we look at the data.
So coming back to
this discussion
of zones and regions,
the bottom line
is not that physical
failures never happen--
yes, they do-- but rather
that they're not actually
what the data tells
us we should focus on,
because they are de
minimis, in terms
of their impact on
your application.
And logical failures
are really the thing
that we must pay attention to.
So for those services
that actually require
physical separation
or physical isolation,
for example, regulatory
reasons, we actually
recommend that you look at using
multiple regions rather than
multiple zones, because both
regions tend to be physically
more distinct than zones.
Zones, on average, with
other cloud providers
are about 10 kilometers
apart from each other.
Regions tend to be
hundreds of kilometers
apart from each other.
And so you get more
physical redundancy for much
of the same logical
work that's required
to make your application
run in multiple locations.
The other reason that we
recommend multiple regions,
however, is that on
all of the providers,
the logical isolation that you
get between different regions
is significantly higher
than the logical isolation
that you get between
zones in the same region.
So in practice, what we see
is that an application that
runs in multiple regions
will have many fewer logical
failures that it's exposed to
than an application that simply
runs in multiple zones
inside the same region.
So at this point, you've got
your user journeys described.
You've got your SLOs.
And you're working
on this question of,
should I use multiple zones, or
should I use multiple regions?
Or is a single was
sufficient for my needs?
You also, at this
point, want to consider
how easy the provider makes
it to deploy instances
of your application
across multiple locations,
whether it's zones or regions.
Generally, all of the
public cloud providers
offer regional versions
of their services
that automatically distribute
the data and processing
and user traffic across
multiple zones in a region.
And you can use their offering,
or you can roll your own.
But generally, what
we would recommend
is that you use the version
of those tools provided
by a provider for two reasons.
One is, they have many
more flight miles on them
than whatever you're
going to build yourself.
And two is, you benefit from
all of the other customers who
are also using those tools,
and therefore, the investment
that the cloud provider
will be making in improving
those tools over time.
And we've seen that
there's a temptation
to look at those systems
and say, well, they
haven't been perfect, so
I should build my own,
because I know I can build
my own perfect system.
But actually, as
experienced professionals,
we all know that building your
own version of a multi-zone,
highly available,
highly performant system
is actually quite tricky.
It's both expensive, in
terms of development time,
and it's difficult to get right.
And then you'll have to maintain
it and improve it for forever.
So I would encourage
you to, by default,
use the tools that
are provided to you
rather than rolling
your own in cases where
those tools are available.
So if you look at the
building blocks, again,
that cloud providers
offer you, we
can see here in this example
map, three basic options.
You can run a service in
a single zone, represented
by one of those circles.
You can run a service
in several zones
inside the same region,
which still means you're
in one of those circles again.
Or you can run your service
in two or three regions,
using one or more zones
in each of those regions.
And you can see that
the separation that you
get physically is quite
large between regions,
so there will be increased
latency between the regions.
But also, there's a great
deal more physical isolation
that's provided by the regions.
And then, as I
mentioned, there's
also a great deal more
logical isolation.
And here again, it's
important to look
at the provider or
providers that you're using,
because different providers
do it differently.
I won't spend time talking
about the other cloud providers.
But in the case of
Google Cloud, we
do offer features that make
running in multiple regions
much easier.
For example, we have
single global interfaces
that allow you to view
and manage the resources
that you've got.
We've got products
that automatically
will allow you to select
a multi-regional offering
and that do data replication
and data processing
across multiple regions.
And then we have a very large,
very high bandwidth backbone
network that allows you to
transfer data between regions
and do load balancing to
distribute your traffic
across multiple regions.
So putting this
all together, what
do you want to look for
in a cloud provider?
And how do you want to think
about your own architecture
for cloud providers?
I would say, first and foremost,
you should ignore the marketing
and look at the data.
The performance data from
the different cloud providers
is different, and each of them
has some pros and some cons.
And you want to look at how
those pros and cons would
affect the application
that you're trying to run
and the availability targets
that you've chosen for yourself
and pick one that's
the best match
for your particular needs.
I would say, secondly,
you want to look
at the strength
of each provider,
in terms of their
infrastructure security.
Infrastructure
attacks themselves
are a reliability problem.
If there's a DDOS,
no one really cares
whether it was your
application or your provider's
infrastructure that
failed to protect you.
All the users will know is their
application stopped working,
and they're angry with you.
And so it's important to look
at the track record of dealing
with large-scale attacks and
large-scale security challenges
and make sure that
the infrastructure
providers that you are using
meet your needs in those
regards.
You should look at the size,
maturity, and scalability
of the provider's
infrastructure,
again, picking on denial
of service attacks.
Those attacks tend
to be very large.
There are public
reports of attacks
in the multi-terabyte range.
And so size does matter,
and scale does matter.
And picking providers that
have both the resources
and the track record to be able
to absorb very large attacks
when they happen will
give you a degree
of security and protection that
you otherwise wouldn't have.
Or similarly, if there has
been a major shift of demand
as a result of,
for example, COVID,
does the provider have the
experience and the track
record of being able to
continue to provide resources
for your application when
and where you need them,
despite this unusual
surge in demand?
You should consider as well
how easily your architects
and developers
can design, build,
and deploy on the
infrastructure that your cloud
provider offers.
How easy is it to
build a system that
spans multiple zones
and multiple regions?
And how much work do they
have to do to maintain or roll
their own system for places
where the infrastructure
provider does not offer
the system that you need?
And then finally,
definitely, if you
have an application that
for regulatory reasons
or other reasons requires
physical separation,
you should look at the physical
location of both data center
zones and data center
regions in order
to pick a solution that
appropriately balances
the latency of zone
or region separation
with the physical and
logical protection that you
get from that separation.
And you should do all of this
with an eye back to those SLOs
that we talked about earlier.
How do I achieve my SLOs
with the minimum of overhead
and, therefore, a
maximum of development
to feature velocity?
So let's now move
on to part 3, which
is how you can implement and
operate a reliable application.
This section is
specifically about what
you can do in your own stack
to take advantage of cloud
and also to reduce the
risk of the outages
in your own codebase.
And these techniques
build on the steps
that we've talked about so far,
using service level indicators,
using service level objectives,
measuring them, and selecting
a cloud provider that
gives you the performance
and flexibility that you want
for your own application.
So within Google, in addition
to thinking about reliability
as how do we minimize
failures, we also think about,
how do we make our service
resilient to the sorts
of failures that we're likely
to see when they do happen?
And we spend as
much time on systems
here at Google which
respond to failures
and mask them from
our users as we
do in preventing those
failures in the first place.
And this principle that
failures are normal,
that we want a good
user experience,
despite a small but continuous
level of failures in systems,
pretty much affects
all the phases
of system design,
development, and deployment.
So I'll talk about two of the
most important areas there,
architecture and design, and
then deployment and operation.
So for architecture
and design, we
recommend taking a
skeptical position
and choosing an
architecture which breaks
your stack into components.
Those components can be
decoupled from each other.
They can be moved around.
They can be scaled up and down.
And this is something that
Cloud makes it very easy to do.
Cloud already offers scalable
and flexible capacity.
It offers multiple
independent zones and regions.
If you have a modern application
design using microservices,
we have products
like Anthos that
make it easy to make components
mobile, to scale them,
and also makes it easy
to detect problems
with individual components
and hone in on them.
If you have a more
traditional application that
runs in virtual machines,
Google Compute Engine
has managed instance
groups, which give you
a similar level of flexibility.
And finally, the idea
of getting resilience
through failure detection
and failure minimization
is a key concept.
If you have load balancing
that can shift traffic
between different
pools of instances,
then you can send small
amounts of user traffic,
for example, to a new
version of the application
and verify that those users are
getting the result you expect
before you increase the
fraction of your application
that uses that new version.
And that way, you can
seamlessly roll users
over to a new version
of the application
without ever putting
too many of them
at the risk of a
new release at once.
And if it isn't working
the way you expect,
you can just send all
of your user traffic
back to the existing
instances that you've
got of the version
of your application
that you know
works, and then you
can debug what might be
wrong at your leisure
without time pressure.
During development,
Cloud also offers
a number of powerful
tools to support
best practices, like
continuous build and testing.
For example, it's very easy
to spin up a whole new test
instance of your
production application
that's decoupled from your
actual production environment.
And there you can test
new versions of components
to make sure everything works
together doing an integration
test and spin it back down.
And that way, by the time you
actually deploy to production,
you have a great
deal of confidence
that the application is going
to work the way you want,
and you've taken advantage of
the same concepts of component
groups and scaling that
you'll use in your production
environment.
So when we talk about
deployment and operation,
I think of the different
areas of reliability.
This one often gets less
attention than it ought--
and I'm not just saying that
because I've spent the last two
decades of my life working
on deployment problems--
but for two reasons,
really, primarily
that the impact of a
change on an application
is somewhat underappreciated.
Most failures that we
see occur during attempts
to change an application.
It's the single largest
cause of outage.
And yet, it's not
the place sometimes
where we spend the
most time making sure
that our practices are safe and
appropriate to the reliability
of the targets that we've got.
And secondly, because change
management is actually hard,
and historically, it's
been difficult to be
sophisticated about
change management.
It can be treated as
sort of a monolithic.
We have the old version.
We have the new version.
We have a failover period.
And that approach is
very, very high stakes.
You have to get everything
right with the new version,
or you'll have a catastrophe.
And so really, when we think
about deployment and operation,
it is a place to take advantage
of a lot of the capabilities
that Cloud gives you
to drastically reduce
the risk of deployment and
the risk of new versions.
And that, in turn,
means that you
can deploy much more frequently
and have a higher development
velocity and, eventually,
then more features
for your users,
which is obviously
a highly desirable trait.
So a few tips.
And this is a deep
area, so I'm just
going to scratch the surface.
But shameless plug
for the SRE book,
if you want to read a
lot more about this.
In general, the best
way to manage a change
and thus minimize the risk
of a change-related outage
is, first of all, to
practice progressive rollout.
And progressive rollout
means that you apply updates
to instances of
your application,
either in different zones
and regions independently
or to small fractions of
your instances first and then
greater fractions as you gain
confidence that everything
is working the way you expect.
And Cloud infrastructure
supports you here,
both with automated
development tool, but also
the automated deployment tools.
Supervision of rollouts
is very, very important.
And supervision, in
particular, means
knowing what you
expect to see and only
continuing with a rollout
if the results are
exactly what you expect, no
more, no less, no different.
A lot of times, what we see
with rollouts that have gone bad
is they weren't overtly failing,
but they weren't behaving
the way that we expected.
And the criteria for
continuing had de facto
been, well, unless it's
breaking, keep rolling out--
and that masks things
like, oops, we're
consuming 6% more memory
than we had expected,
which is fine at the
time you're doing
the rollout during a
local trough of traffic.
But the next morning
when peak traffic rolls
around, it turns out,
that's a problem.
And so this idea of
knowing what to expect
and only proceeding
with a rollout
when it's working
the way you expect
gives you a great deal of safety
for really extremely low cost.
And then in addition
to rollout, obviously,
if things aren't working
well, your rollbacks
need to be fast, safe, and easy.
Some of the outage
postmortems that we've done--
one of the reasons that
the outage occurred
was that the team that was
in the middle of the rollout
was nervous about rolling back
when the system wasn't behaving
the way they expected, and
that has a predictable result.
If your rollbacks
are fast and safe
and your application was working
before you start changing it,
then hitting the big rollback
button the first moment
that something isn't
going the way you expect
becomes habit for
everyone, and that
actually will save you from
a ton of avoidable outages.
And then finally, designing your
application so that it fails
in a way that gives you
a reasonable result--
we call it fail static--
but things like you get
a configuration change,
and you send that
configuration change
to the first
instance of your app.
And that instance of the app
stops responding for whatever
reason-- maybe it's crashloop,
maybe it's just not able
to parse the
configuration, whatever--
the application at
that point can say,
well, I'm not sure
what's going on,
but I know that it
was working fine
before this change started.
So I'm just going to stop
applying changes to the app
fail static and fire an alarm
that asks the human to come
and look for me.
And this is this
idea of fail static.
It can save you from a great
number of unexpected behaviors
during a rollout or during
a change with essentially
no cost, again, to your user,
because the application just
continues to work the
way it used to work.
And Cloud can really help you
in a number of these practices,
because it offers
scalable infrastructure,
so that you can spin up
and spin down instances.
During a rollout, you can
have extra their capacity
to run both new and old
side-by-side, for example.
It allows you to test.
It allows you to monitor the
behavior of your application.
And it gives you insights
into the behavior
of individual components,
so that you can look at,
is it working the way it used to
work, not just at the SLO level
and through your user
journeys, but actually
at the component level?
And this gives you a
great deal of safety.
So in summary, that
was a whirlwind tour
of reliability in the cloud.
It's, like I said, my
life's work at this point.
And it's a very,
very deep topic.
But we have at least
covered a number
of the most important
and most salient points
for building and winning
reliable applications
in the [INAUDIBLE]
from the cloud.
And my goal today
really was to give you
a framework about
thinking about these three
major steps in your
cloud reliability
journey and entry to those steps
to give you some specific ideas
to get you started down
the process of more
detailed planning.
Developing for
reliability in the cloud
can require some new thinking
and a change in perspective,
but it also gives you a
great deal of flexibility
and a great deal of power.
And I can assure
you from experience,
it is a step function.
Once you've looked at building
reliable applications this way,
you won't look at them in the
old way very often anymore.
And I hope this has
been helpful for you,
both in thinking
through that process,
thinking through
assessing your application
and your measurable
availability goals,
thinking through how to
select a public cloud
provider or providers,
and leveraging the systems
and tools and structures that
they have available to make
your application more reliable.
And finally, to help you think
about architecture, design,
deployment, and operation
of your application
to anticipate and work through
a wide [? variability ?]
challenged suite, including
reliability challenges that
are triggered by
your own actions,
as well as those that
may occur as the result
of exogenous events.
Thank you so much, and
good luck to everyone.